typically starts with a sneeze
spring in europe always sparks a stream
of sniffly noses
and itchy eyes
this season though scientists are
warning of a phenomenon known as the
pollen effect
they've linked high pollen levels with a
rising covert
the researchers say many factors can
affect infection rates
but let's take a closer look at
allergies and the coronavirus
well that picture's enough to get me
sneezing i always yearn for spring
after the long cold german winter but i
don't look forward to all the allergies
especially considering all the headlines
going around about pollen
and covert co-exposure to airborne
pollen enhances your susceptibility to
respiratory
viral infections a study shows that
could also be true for sars coffee too
we'll talk to one of the authors about
that in a moment first
this report spring is in the air
for many that means time to enjoy the
outdoors
but for people like benedict schmitz
spring means allergies
my throat starts tingling and i have to
be careful not to touch my eyes
otherwise they start to itch
early blossoms can play havoc with the
nose and eyes hazelnut and alderpollen
are problematic for many
benedict's main issue is with grass
pollen but during the pandemic he's
often asking himself whether his
symptoms are to do with his allergy or
possibly coronavirus instead
of i think everyone who experiences such
symptoms probably ask themselves the
same question
you become a kind of hobby hypochondriac
when my throat starts scratching or i
feel
sleepy typically after i've taken an
allergy tablet i start to worry whether
this might be coronavirus
indeed the symptoms of many allergies
are pretty similar to those of covert 19
sore throat coughing sneezing tiredness
benedict books an appointment with an
allergy specialist to ask which symptoms
point to a coronavirus infection
relatively common is a loss of smell
that's something you really experience
with allergies
and certainly not to the extent that you
completely lose your sense of smell
so that would be a clear indicator that
you may have a coronavirus infection
itchy eyes would suggest it's not
coronavirus whereas a fever would
exhaustion a dry cough that really
persists these would suggest something
like a covert 19 infection
but experienced allergy sufferers know
at what time of the year they tend to
get symptoms
benedict schmitz is now confident he
doesn't need to be tested for
coronavirus
but what about his allergy symptoms
because of the pandemic
the doctor recommends medicating early
so that sneezing is kept to a minimum
cortisone nose sprays for example can
help with that
that isn't harmful
cortisone shouldn't be injected or taken
in a tablet form to treat allergies
except in an absolute emergency because
then it can really have side effects
but the thing about cortisone sprays is
that the cortisone in them only has an
effect in the nasal area
there are no adverse effects on the rest
of the body
a spring free of sneezes and itchy eyes
and others can rest assured
it's an allergy and not covered claudia
treitel hofmann is director of the
institute of environmental medicine in
munich and was involved in a study into
exactly this topic
what did you find exactly what do pollen
allergies have in common
with covert then in this study we bring
a new and previously
unnoticed aspect into the equation of
pandemic fuelling it's not just about
aerosols that are key drivers of viral
pandemic but it's rather the complexity
of the aerosols so we show in a large
study that
increased dust of two infections are
observed
when airborne pulmonary and this is the
result of a large study
with 100 130 pollen monitoring stations
in 3100 over five continents
and really the finding is in the last
spring there was
a coincidence and a correlation of the
ask of two infection rates
rising and upon concentrations
and of note the lowest infection rates
were observed at sites with low pollen
concentration
during the study period okay so why do
infection rates rise when there's a lot
of pollen in the air
so the molecular finding behind this
is that pollen weaken the anti-viral
defense of mucosal surfaces
like nose and upper airway you can
imagine that it's
like a perforated shield that
pollen induce so normally we have a
shield against viruses and
and porn are yeah making
this leaky and this is why during porn
season we are more susceptible
for viral infection spring is already
here and my eyes have been itching like
crazy
should i be worried i have a pollen
allergy obviously
this is very important to know so it's
not only about
pollen allergy it's beyond pollen
allergies so this is an
unspecific effect this has nothing to do
with allergies
this is something we are observing in
every individual
there's been criticism of this study
despite it being
so broad and global how greater risk
is pollen for people with allergies or
without allergies
so the criticism that has been there is
that people
are are not citing that we we observed
a a common effect of several
environmental factors
pollen humidity and temperature
and all together are important for a
variability
of infection rates and important is the
following
it's about the personal risks that
cannot be
um concluded from the study so i cannot
say that mr mueller has
this and that probability to get an
infection due to pollen so
this is something we have now to
investigate in further studies
we know that pollen are impacting on the
mucosal
immunity and this is clear but
concerning the personal risks there's
nothing
to to say from this study what would you
say then are the
actual consequences of your study
so inclusion and towards the one health
approach
the variable missing from the pandemic
equation
is to to really look for the whole
environment
impacting on infection rates
and this is why we suggest that we
should really bring these environmental
factors in
modulation in also prediction
of what is happening in the future and
we need
really dedicated large stale scale bioma
biomonitoring studies on characterized
patients in order to understand
the environmental impact on this
pandemic
well i hope you get that support because
i'm going to be sneezing and getting
itchy eyes for
quite some time claudio tyler hoffmann
director of the institute of
environmental medicine in munich thank
you very much for joining us today
i thank you bye
for today's viewer question on the
coronavirus it's over to
our science correspondent derek williams
i have asked ma can i get a covet-19
vaccine
the centers for disease control still
considers asthma
as one of the conditions that might
increase the risk
of severe outcomes if you come down with
covid19
but data continues to accumulate that at
least
for people who have moderate forms of
the disease
asthma doesn't pose as big of a risk
factor
as other chronic conditions like for
example
diabetes when you start looking into
this topic the recommendation you read
over
and over again is that no matter what
happens
if you have asthma it's important to
keep it under control
by following your action plan since an
asthma attack that forces you to go
to an emergency room puts you at
more danger of exposure to stars kobe 2.
the answer to the question of whether
you should get a covet 19 vaccine
is is a resounding yes national asthma
associations recommend people
who have the autoimmune condition get
shots as soon as they have the
opportunity
uh in trials coveted vaccines were given
to subjects
of many different ages among them people
with
chronic conditions like asthma and and
the hundreds
of millions of shots given worldwide
since
have not given rise to any specific
vaccine related cause for alarm
for people who live with it i did find a
recommendation
from the british lung foundation saying
that
although the vaccine is not known to
interact with
medications if you take monoclonal
antibodies for your asthma
then then you should talk to your doctor
about how to time
when you get your vaccine so so take
that into consideration
but in general all of the experts that i
read
are saying that you should get the shot
as soon as you can
now to some of the other coronavirus
related stories making news
astrazeneca says its coronavirus vaccine
is strongly effective following its
disputed u.s study
after recalculating the data from that
study instead of 79
efficacy the pharma firm concluded that
the vaccine is 76
effective in preventing symptomatic
covert
nonetheless danish authorities have
extended their suspension of the vaccine
pending further studies in correlation
with blood clots
the u.s senate has confirmed rachel
levine as the first transgender person
to hold
a senior government position in the
united states the president's pick as
assistant health secretary levine led
pennsylvania's response
to the coronavirus outbreak she will
oversee health and human services
the tokyo olympics torch relay is
underway under strict conditions to stop
the spread of the coronavirus
spectators were barred from the
departure ceremony because of ongoing
fears about the virus which forced the
2020 games to be postponed last year
the torch is on a 121 day relay across
japan before
lighting the olympic cauldron on july
23rd
and a new record for banksy the piece
game changer sold for 19.4 million euros
at christie's in london with the
proceeds going to britain's
national health service it pays tribute
to frontline health workers in the
pandemic praising nurses
as the real superheroes the elusive
street artists had given the piece to
university hospital in
southampton with a note saying thanks
for all you're doing
you